hello info
and welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet that does physics
rationally everybody else does
mathematics irrational physical
interpretations they have no clue how
this universe works
anyways I'm going to do some questions
at the end of the uh show
lots of questions and comments so I'm
going to cover a few of those and uh
we're going to be talking about the
universe what in the world is the
universe can we say can we put an
article like the
you know or a universe can we do that in
physics and science
or can we be allowed to do that only in
ordinary speech yeah we'll find out
today anyways let's start with our
Extinction segment we had some issues
that were raised they have to do with a
lot of what's going on in the world
today you know in the uh
letter World lots of letters you know
what I'm talking about
okay let's go with the first one this
comes from our inclusion and diversity
department and says that God is
transitioning
okay just like you hear it says the
Church of England opening project on
gendered language guess what that's
about
using prayer and in scripture the
announcement suggested that church
Authority consider whether to do away
with gendered he him pronouns referring
to God
it would consider whether father is an
appropriate title for God
our spiritual York uh fellow named
Stephen Cottrell uh suggested that the
words of of the Our Father Christianity
more prominent prayer may be problematic
because of their patriarchal Association
the word father is problematic for those
whose experience of Earthly fathers has
been destructive and abusive and for all
of us who have labored rather too much
from an oppressively patriarchal grip on
life don't know what kind of problems he
had uh and there's a lady Reverend
Christina Reese added the big question
is do we really believe that God
believes that male human beings bear His
Image more fully and accurately than
women
the answer is absolutely not
hey so
um uh I don't know what uh what God
looks like you know I mean I can't tell
you uh
uh the Bible says uh God is male and uh
even the Muslims believe that God is
male
um you know and other religions some
religion believe that God is a woman a
goddess uh I guess you know
so I don't know what's coming up but if
uh all these changes are going on uh in
which
um you know they're changing everything
uh the pronouns and so on I'm wondering
what God is going to look like next and
I just I can't tell you this is what God
is going to look like but all I can tell
you is maybe this is the way it's going
okay here you see uh God transitioning
so I suspect that you know pretty soon
we're gonna have to call God a she or a
they or who knows Okay so just keep that
in mind
we do have a weird world at the end of
our existence
and that's what you're seeing around you
it's it's as crazy as it gets okay
raises an issue he says atrazine causes
sex change in frogs
okay it made me think immediately of
pearl froggy I I think you remember him
from one of our cartoons uh way back
when okay and there you have them and
yeah this was the singing frog he'd sing
uh hello my baby right hello my darling
or my honey and it turns out that you
know
um
now they're saying that he does more
than just sing okay turns out that uh
this frog now is going to change his sex
because of a chemical right okay so
um just wondering about that all I can
say is that you know uh these people
never answer the question and the
questions out there for you you can
answer if you want you can say that
chemicals are doing it you can say all
the rich people in the world are putting
us in Corrals and feeding us garbage and
that's why we're having all this
homosexuality and autism out there in
the world you got to answer the question
that we put here and no one has
addressed it they just want to give
their opinion it's usually a political
opinion you know and that's what you got
to answer you got to answer whether
Lions also have atrazine and whether uh
sheep have atrazine okay lions and Lambs
that's what it's all about okay and uh
obviously there are other animals that
have homosexuality and and there's also
autism
um
you remember a Calhoun you know I
mentioned him a couple times already he
ran his experiments for about 30 years
and he was able to reproduce in the lab
he was able to produce It For the First
Time homosexuality and autism without
any chemicals without any
um you know injections or any of those
things that these people mention so you
gotta answer how do you produce
homosexuality and autism in the lab and
I'm saying that you know it's got to do
with founders effect
and
um
you know primarily that one in other
words there's a genetic problem because
several Generations come from the same
grandfathers okay and you see that also
among Amish I mentioned this also before
Amish have genetic disorders there's
also by the way homosexuality among
um Amish you can look it up Amish
homosexuality and uh yeah they have all
these uh genetic disorders they're
they're known to be genetic and why are
they genetic because these people have
been inbreeding for the last 300 400
years
and so yeah at some point you do have
problems you know uh uh Charles II of
Spain Carlos
he was known as the Bewitched
and uh why because he came from a long
line of habsburgs and they kept marrying
between them you know finally uh it hit
the this generation the one from Charles
and uh he was born uh not so uh not so
healthy okay and he was in the only one
look at the Nicholas's the Second Son in
Russia
uh Alex a he uh had hemophilia and why
because they all came from the same
families in fact uh both
um Nick and Nikki as they call Nicholas
and his wife they both descended from
Queen Victoria so uh yeah you can I mean
why did they stop allowing uh marriages
you know in the old days between father
and daughter son and mother
uh sister and brother you know all those
relations stopped
and it's probably they probably realized
something was happening okay you can't
have such closeness you know uh not only
from a moral point of view which is a
question of opinion but you do have a
biological issue Okay so
um I think that's that's the issue the
issue is you can't inbreed for too long
because Mother Nature will eventually
kill your species okay
and I think that's what happened to the
Neanderthals anyways uh here's uh
another fellow he says in Antiquity
homosexuality was very prevalent
and this is such a popular misconception
that everybody has out there you know
instead of just stating this you should
answer the questions I mean here here
the question here is I present the
issues and I'm showing you some uh
evidence from from the record from the
historical record I mean we don't know
exactly what happened all we can do is
go buy the record and you can believe
whatever we want from the record but
there's the record uh address it okay
you have to address it okay you may say
I don't believe in that record okay fine
no problem but here you have uh showed
uh all these codes uh dating to about 2
000 years ago maybe from 1750 all the
way to 2000 plus uh years before Christ
right and none of these had any
references to homosexuality it was
approximately 1100 years ago in fact
they say it does extend all the way to
the 14th century before uh Christ the
code of Surah whether it included some
of these uh
Clauses is is a separate issue but the
point is that around 1100 BC uh that's
when they started putting homosexual
Clauses in the codes okay for the first
time at least that's an objective record
if you can find it before then find you
know show us but right now this is the
record this is the official record and
you can see there you know that
number 19 says if a man has had
unnatural intercourse with his companion
if it has been proven in a certain he
has unnatural intercourse with him he
shall be what castrated and yeah
homosexuality was always looked on uh as
something
terrible something bad something to be
punished it was never at all favored in
any I mean I've been researching this
for a long time and I'm telling you the
Aztecs the Vikings the uh you know the
Romans the Greeks they all punished
homosexuality okay nobody saw that as
anything good and here you have Greece
in Rome you know I also pointed this out
last time and you know there's several
over there you'll see the Alexis Cantina
in Rome but the main one really is
though that you should look up is the
one in the middle there against Demarcus
uh and why is that one important well it
involved these three individuals okay uh
the mostenes escanese and Philip II of
Macedon uh demosthenes and escanies were
uh big shots in Athens okay so what
happened
um Athens sent escanese to the court of
Philip uh second of Macedon who was the
big man the guy who had the big army and
he was about to come down to Athens to
make it uh you know to beat him up and
so they sent escanies there to reach an
agreement with uh Philip and he finally
came back after two trips and said hey
you know we've got a peace treaty we're
okay and Masini is simply accused uh
escanese of being
um a spy really you know betraying
Athens and so they they held a trial
against escanese and asking is the only
thing he did he said look you know the
guy who's bringing charges against me
which was his fellow to Marcus on behalf
of the most Indies
um this guy Tim Marcus uh you know SNES
just brings out code of Athens and what
he does is he has really the trial
turned around against Demarcus and says
you know this man has no right to sue me
to to bring me to court to bring charges
against me because he is a homosexual
and so instead of uh regarding escanese
as a Trader they regarded to Marcus they
took away his citizenship
according to the masteries and
supposedly he committed suicide they
don't know that exactly what happened to
Demarcus after that but uh what happens
in the trial and we have the the trial
today okay and what eskinese does he
reads out the code against homosexuality
the whole code
Athens hated homosexuals and of course
they didn't try a measly over homosexual
that had no name that wasn't of no
importance but here it was very
important and so they did try to Marcus
on on that basis and they took away his
citizenship that's how simple it was
then supposedly he committed suicide so
this is what you got to answer you got
to answer you know
um these are the questions before you
don't just say well you know everybody
was homosexual in the past you know
that's just a statement you you haven't
shown any evidence of that and all
you're doing parroting homosexual
propaganda you know I mean at least put
something that you did some you know
some research that you did and say well
I looked this up and this is what I
found and you'll probably find the same
thing I find okay because that's that is
in the record
okay let's move on to our universe what
is a universe okay we've been dealing
lately with um
the universal movie as I call it and
um it allows us to distinguish specially
this concept known as the universal
movie I call it a tool it allows us to
distinguish between uh static Concepts
and Dynamic Concepts okay and here it is
uh just uh
for
Pi but on the other side give me a
second here
these are so touchy sometimes okay so
this is the universal moving what are we
showing now well we're showing uh frames
of the film you got to think of the
universe as you know if you take a
snapshot of the universe at any point in
time you got God's camera you can make
it a three-dimensional uh frame if you
want no problem okay this is God's
camera so he can do that so we have a
three-dimensional uh movie okay we film
it and we just take one frame of that
film
well nothing hopefully nothing will be
moving within that frame okay all you
have there is every atom in the universe
some form part of uh planets others of
stars of asteroids whatever gases so you
have every adamant in the universe is
standing still
okay we got that that's what's in one
frame okay and so all we have is
existence all we have is location right
every object at a given location and
there's a separation between that atom
and every atom in the universe that's
how you see in the movie in in the
single frame there's no Motion in that
single frame okay that's the notion and
the question is uh where are we going to
put the universe are we going to put it
as a static concept is it a physical
object is it a dynamic uh concept what
is a universe okay uh you hear you will
hear people talk about the expanding
Universe about the curvature of the
universe right whether the universe is
finite or infinite you know you get all
these so people treat it as a physical
object
and the question is is the universe a
physical object is it a container
and if so what's outside of the
container giving the container shape
you know these are the questions these
are valid questions at least in physics
okay so what is the problem the problem
is we have a difference between physics
real physics and what they call
mathematical physics which is
mathematics which is not physics at all
which is not even science it's just math
with irrational explanations that's all
they have but irrational physical
interpretations okay and so here we have
the difference you see them side by side
how they how each of us looks at the
universal movie a little bit differently
uh math is mathematics they emphasize
experiment and evidence
in physics real physics science
emphasizes reasoning
uh math is what they do is describe and
predict they use equations equations to
describe okay numbers equations Etc and
in physics we don't use equations at all
we just want to explain qualitatively
how this universe works
Mathis emphasizes persuasion convincing
converting recruiting you know and
physics only wants you to understand
once you understand we're done with
physics what continues is religion which
includes persuasion convincing
converting and recruiting
proof knowledge in fact those are words
that the mathematicians use in science
we do not use those words we use causes
and mechanisms that's what we want to
understand we want to know how gravity
Works how a magnet attracts another how
electricity works that kind of stuff so
for that we need causes and mechanisms
in order to
visualize mechanism understand them
right we need objects but that's not
what Matthews is math uses Mass because
they're interested in the numbers in the
quantities in the units stuff that they
can put in an equation
they can put the word object in an
equation they can't put the word star in
an equation they can't put the word
planet in an equation so what they do
they put the mass of the star the mass
of the planet okay that's what they're
interested in so they're they're
interested in calculations and that has
nothing to do with physics in physics we
need to explain the mechanisms we want
to understand how this universe works
and here we are ten thousand twenty
thousand years later right and nobody
can tell you how gravity Works how
magnet sticks to your refrigerator you
know without using Concepts and what
they do is they always use the words
that represent Concepts such as field
and mass and charge and those kinds of
words energy
anyways um observation and measurement
that's what math does and emphasize that
we do not use measurement or observation
we do not use our eyes what we use is
the mind we use our brains and what
we're trying to figure out is what
exists out there okay and again you can
use the universal movie to find out what
exists uh simply by you know if you
could take a snapshot that's what exists
of the universe that's what exists and
you would have find every atom somewhere
in the universe at a given separation
from all others that's what you would
find in a single frame of the universe a
movie and so we do not have to have
observation for that or measurement this
is a conceptual issue
um mathematics they emphasize numbers
and units and number lines we don't use
those in physics we use Dimensions
coordinates and vectors you know like
with height longitude altitude latitude
and the vectors are deaf breath and
elevation
uh the mathematicians they like
displacement distance travel they have
to have something in motion all their
concepts by the way are Dynamic uh in
physics we use we first have to
determine separation distance distance
just separation between two objects
uh they use words such as energy force
field and charge and we do not care
about those we care about the physical
mediation we need to identify the
physical mediators and if we cannot see
your touch them what we do is Imagine
them to find out how Mother Nature is
doing her mechanism okay and we get to
the real Crux of the issue which is time
versus location okay and mathematicians
emphasize time and Physics empathizes
location
uh so what is the issue the issue is
that um yeah
I'll put in a little uh picture for you
okay here you have physics okay and we
have a single frame that's all we care
about we want to know what's in that
single frame that that will tell us what
exists in the universe we just stopped
the universe we take the snapshot
and uh we can see every little atom in
the universe in that snapshot okay
that's how good that uh camera is that's
how good the frame of the film is we've
taken a snapshot of the universe now
we're going to inspect a single frame
okay there's nothing moving in that
frame hopefully unless you drank too
much beer okay and so we can figure out
what exists you know that's what's in
that frame existence that's all you have
there you have location you have
distance all these static Concepts can
be found within that single frame on the
other hand uh mathematical mathematical
physics mathematics right they're
interested in time so what they look at
is many frames okay and so they tell you
that you know time at one side of the
universe is different than time at the
other side of the universe
and that is somewhat of a problem
because
um you know um
we're talking about location and
hopefully in a cross-section of time
cross-section of motion right single
snapshot only where we only have
location a static concept all we have is
you know every atom in the universe has
a given location with respect to all
others at that in that single frame okay
that's what exists but when you talk
about time you're talking about hey I'm
going to be traveling I'm going to be
measuring I'm going to be observing I'm
going to be doing all those things that
mathematicians do I'm going to travel to
the other side of the universe and it
turns out that if I travel faster uh
time has a different uh value okay and
uh there's a different time on the other
side of the universe depending on how
fast I travel and to get into all this
uh nonsense and uh because of that they
get into weird conclusions like you know
you can travel back in time or forward
in time and this is more or less what's
happening let me put it here for you
here it is keep keep an eye on this
you know you leave the present and you
can go to the Past okay
and so what's the issue the issue is
that you your rocket ends up in some
kind of frame in the past they say in
other words what they think is happening
is that or at least what they believe is
that mother nature Colette or father
universe or God or the devil one of
those guys collects all these frames of
the film okay and when you leave the
Earth you're going to go into the past
for example right and you're going to
fall in one of those frames because
Mother Nature preserved it in her file
cabinet for you
okay this is what they think because
they're talking about math they're now
talking about real physical reality I
mean what the what these people think is
that the past is somehow filed and
there's a physical past that you can go
to with your rocket okay and yeah what
happens is you can uh end up killing
your grandfather
[Laughter]
okay so this is what uh they allow you
to do uh not only that what you can do
is go to the Future
and um in the same way in other words
not only can you go to the past but you
can go to the to what has not happened
all because of this time thing
and the question is is there a file
cabinet with all these frames of the
film you know three-dimensional frames
right with all the objects there for you
to land in the future
okay and again here it is uh for your
visualization you're going to go from
the present you're going to go to the
Future okay
and you're gonna land
inside some kind of frame that Mother
Nature has in the future
and so what happens is uh you're gonna
jump into that frame more or less like
uh Mary Poppins I don't know if you saw
the movie but you should and you'll see
this okay here it is
and they're going to jump into a frame
of the movie okay
and they're going into this Fantasy Land
this is what the mathematicians are
telling you okay
they actually believe that this is
possible that these frames are available
for you to jump into you know go into
the future of the past because these
frames exist okay they're there and
they're not just you know history
they're solid it's like there is an
earth with that frame of the film with
all the locations of every atom in the
universe and you're going to that
frame of the film three-dimensional Gods
God's movie right here we're talking
about right and you're gonna land in
there and you're gonna do like Mary
Poppins you're just gonna jump into the
frame and there you are you know and
this is what they believe
and they say it's not a religion
okay so we look up you know what is this
thing we call universe is it a physical
entity is it a concept what is it and it
turns out you know none of the you know
think tanks out there the important ones
the ones that are official for physics
or mathematical physics right uh none of
them tell you what a universe is
uh the closest one I could get to is a
Wolfram uh Eric uh Weiss uh times uh
physics site and this is what you'll
find you'll find the word Universe in
there but they don't Define the word
Universe what they say is the age of the
universe blah blah blah blah blah who
cares about the age I need to know what
what the word Universe means first and
they don't Define that word and what
you'll see is that they talk about
curvature of the universe expansion of
the universe they talk about all this
nonsense big bang and so on and they
never Define the word universe so we
don't have any idea what they're talking
about you would think that an important
word like universe is they're going to
talk about the expansion of the universe
treating it like a physical object right
the universe is expanding uh what is it
what expanse a balloon you know a ball
maybe you know a beach ball when you
inflate it uh you know uh one of those
rubber wraps
you blow in it expands that's an
expansion you can expand something
that's physical
so when they talk about the expansion of
the universe are they talking about what
a physical object what is it that is
expanding that's the question you got to
answer okay okay so you can't find it in
any of the official sites I had to go to
Stanford find out if you know the the
stanfordians you know the uh Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy if they had any
reference they don't have the word
Universe what they do have is cosmology
and they talk about you know the
philosophy of cosmology and it says
cosmology the study of physical Universe
okay great so what is the universe we
don't know because they didn't Define
the word okay so uh began as a branch of
theoretical physics through Einstein's
1917 static model of the universe okay
as recently as 1960 cosmology was widely
regarded as a branch of philosophy in
other words the word Universe did not
belong to physics okay it belonged
really to philosophy only philosophers
allegedly talk about talked about
um the universe it has transitioned to
an extremely active area of mainstream
physics and astronomy particularly due
to the application to the early Universe
of atomic and nuclear physics there
exists only one Universe I wonder what
this Multiverse stuff then is all about
so there is nothing else similar to
compare it with okay
this means it is the historical science
par Excellence it deals with only one
unique object
that is the only member of its class
that exists physically okay so it's an
object that exists physically that's
what these people say that the universe
is okay they're treating it as a
physical object not as an abstract
concept okay and so yeah you say okay
maybe it's just a a solid thing you know
that you can kick like a table or
something like that turns out when you
look at the definitions that we have for
the word universe and remember we only
Define Concepts okay we don't Define
objects objects we point to Concepts we
Define okay and so they Define it and so
they defy the the fine uh
Notions okay they defy this because they
should be uh pointing and saying that's
the universe they should give us a
picture of the universe and uh many
times they put it Beyond you they say
it's four dimensional and you cannot
imagine it so that way they got rid of
the problem okay okay so here you see
all these uh sources Wikipedia
Britannica uh NASA and life science and
they'll give it a a shot to try to
define this word but again they don't do
a scientific job on it they just Define
it very Loosely again you can see
they're all very similar they're in fact
there is no difference between them
essentially some leave some parts out
some put them in like Wikipedia includes
time and energy
time is part of the universe energy is
part of the universe two concepts what
do concepts have to be you know doing
what is what are they doing within the
container known as a as as uh the
universe if if the universe is a
container right but see you see uh they
say it's space time uh matter and
energies that's essentially uh What uh
Universe stands for according to
Wikipedia Britannica does an even worse
job because it gets rid of space
altogether they don't put it they didn't
even put space in there okay they just
put energy and matter and says uh
therefore uh the human race is in there
and is that what the universe is
a place where we inhabit like a house or
something like that
uh NASA contains what energy
how can it contain energy energy is not
a physical average you can't contain
energy because energy is a mathematical
concept look it up you'll find out
energy is not a physical object if it is
a physical object all you got to do is
illustrate it for us you know put it on
the table and so we know what energy
looks like okay and uh includes time
also includes time in there okay they
put this concept in there okay uh what
does life science do well it says it's
everything it's like God you know God is
everything okay we solved the problem
okay if God is everything God is nothing
as well and if the universe is
everything you know it's also nothing as
well
okay in any way they include energy
everything you experience even all your
experiences are part of the universe
so they they just put all Concepts that
you can imagine everything you know
every action
uh so we have no idea what the universe
is because uh they never defined it
scientifically you know what is
everything are you talking about God is
that what universe is just the synonym
of the word God God is everything and
again what is God's God is is a thing or
or a concept which one do you pray to do
you pray to intelligence and love on the
one hand or do you pray to this man
that's got a magic wand on the other and
can grant your wish you know a Genie or
whatever
so you know you got to determine whether
God is a concept or an object and the
same thing with the universe is it an
object or is it a concept and if it's an
object don't Define it don't tell us
anything just point
okay that's how that's how you present
an object in physics in science
okay uh what is the universe comprised
of you know maybe we can figure out from
that you know what the universe is well
these are the answers from general
relativity and I've just pulled over a
few these are the most important ones at
least maybe there's a couple others but
uh we've already covered energy time
sometimes space matters sometimes your
behavior your experiences they put all
that stuff in there and they say it's
everything great we don't know what the
universe is like that
um then we have other people who say
it's events that's known as points also
known as happenings and one fellow who
vouches for that is good old Mr
um Stephen Hawking who died a few years
ago an event is something that happens
at a particular point in time in space
in a particular time so one can specify
it with by four numbers or coordinates
it is often helpful to think of the four
coordinates of an event as specifying
its position in a four-dimensional space
called space-time it is impossible to
imagine a four-dimensional space okay so
uh the way he inves uh Hawking
envisioned this and I guess a lot of
people would agree with him since he was
a important Guru in mathematics and
imagine imagine it is all these little
dots and each dot represents an event
and a happening that's why it got him
moving because they're not standing
still uh you would think that they're
moving if it's a happening if it's
something that happens okay so that's
kind of weird that you would represent a
verb with a DOT okay but this is a to
what he is defining describing okay so
that's one way of looking at this
and um you know there's a what we
covered last week we covered the
gravitational waves okay and that's
another way of visualizing what's inside
the universe okay and they look more or
less like this
uh
where is it here
ah give me a second
and uh here you have two black holes
that are twirling around they create
these waves and what in something they
call space time
well again what is space time well space
time is another word for the word
Universe okay so uh what is the universe
again we're trying to figure out what
it's made out of and they'll show you
stuff like this for example okay uh I
guess this would be
um
Stephen Hawking's version all these
points uh events and that's what's
waving
that's the best I can imagine they never
Illustrated so you know you got to do it
for them
okay so if that's what uh space time is
a bunch of dots that are waving right
and so you have these two black holes
they Collide or they whatever they shaky
uh space time around them and all these
waves come all the way to us so what is
it that's waving what is this what is
the universe comprised of what what does
it consist of that's the question we're
trying to answer right what material
thing is there okay and um
here we have uh
uh similar version of that okay this is
uh space time right and what is space
time well it's just a bunch of uh not
even coordinate what they are is number
lines okay you have the number line
known as time which is not a coordinate
it's not a dimension it's not a vector
it's it's a number line that's all time
is and space is also they put the word
space which is ridiculous because they
should be putting length width and
height uh which is what they mean but
actually it's not even length within
height what they're talking about are
number lines they're saying there's
three mutually perpendicular number
lines uh which can't be the case because
number lines don't have Direction they
don't have perpendicularity you can put
numbers in any direction you want okay
in fact they don't have that be in a
line in any way shape or form so what
they're talking about is four number
lines that's what space time is and we
can't say the four number lines are
shaking and that's what a gravitational
wave is so we've got a problem here you
know we've got a problem because they're
not identifying the object that's waving
when they talk about gravitational waves
moving through space time or being the
vibration the oscillation of space-time
itself
because space time itself is just four
coordinates one of which is uh for
number lines one of which is number line
time okay so that doesn't help us
anything we're not talking about
physical objects we will not understand
the mechanisms if we do not identify the
physical objects so so far we got
nothing
um here's a another version and that's a
matter uh Dark Matter dark energy right
they have these things and
um in between there they put these black
holes and wormholes and other stuff in
there and this is more or less what
they're proposing give me a second here
here it goes
okay so they we have a small percentage
which is the Luminous manner matter then
we have non-luminous matter a little
more we have a lot of Dark Matter 23 and
most of the universe is just Dark Energy
some stuff there called Energy and in
between they put black holes and
wormholes okay so this is the notion
these people have of um of what the
universe contains what it's made of okay
this is what they're uh searching for
okay that's what they're trying to
locate I don't know how they can locate
if uh dark matter and dark energy are
admittedly invisible and intangible
which is their version of the word
object of the word thing so here's a
thing that cannot be touched or seen and
they're trying to locate it how do they
plan to locate it indirectly you know
they say if something moves in space
it's because there's some Mass a concept
not an object just a concept close by a
lot of mass that's moving it from a
distance
so they never show you the mechanism
they just say it is so mathematically we
measured and that's what we came up with
and take it or leave it if that's not a
religion I don't know what is okay
okay so um
we're still trying to figure out what
it's uh made out of okay and we're
saying it's made out of matter and space
that's all there is okay and here you
have uh by the way uh in the case of uh
dark matter they they sent this probe
these a few days ago uh the Euclid uh
project uh run by the European space
agency and they are trying to locate the
dark matter that in the dark energy by
the way as well they're trying to locate
this indirectly again because they say
they cannot detect it directly
okay so um uh again these people believe
that this stuff is out there and this is
what everybody on Earth other think
tanks are are searching and
investigating and that's what all your
dollars are spent for for them doing
research on this inexistent dark matter
this inexistent dark energy in existing
black holes and in existent uh wormholes
you know all that stuff that's out there
that is invisible and tangible that's
what they're looking for they're trying
to prove it get a Nobel Prize for
proving their existence and now in
science we say look it's very simple and
what is uh
what is uh the universe we just need to
Define it and we Define it as this
that's which we see out there and what
do you see there you see space and
matter that's all you have out there
okay that's what it looks like that's
what the universe looks like no fourth
dimensional no four coordinates uh no
energy no Fields
uh no gravitational waves none of that
stuff all we have are out there are
atoms that form big objects such as
stars and planets and and space and we
don't have to use the word empty because
Space by definition is empty because
it's not an object it's not a thing and
I think uh it's what we call nothing and
nothing is that which has no shape
because a thing is that which has shape
okay so it's the opposite they're
antonyms okay so how do we do this in
science how do we get to the bottom of
this in science in physics well we have
to define words that way we know what
we're talking talking about so we say
that an object is that which has shape
and a concept is a word that embodies or
invokes two objects or two words treated
you know temporarily as objects and
there you have uh the synonyms relation
ideas attract abstraction comparison Etc
contrast okay so
um object is the one where a concept is
to two Okay so uh that's a good way of
thinking about it mother nature provided
all objects humans invented all Concepts
we invented the universe meaning uh
Mother Nature put the objects there okay
and she didn't put them there they were
always there but or father Universe one
of those guys uh but uh we are the one
who established the relation between
objects you know the things like planets
and stars and this black space you know
the dark stuff that's around every
object out there and we we have two
things there it's not a thing space is
not a thing but we treat it like it says
there in the definition we treat it
momentarily as a and we say look there's
a comparison between two things space
and matter
and that's what uh uh the universe is
objects we point to Concepts we Define
so uh Universe we have to Define how do
we find how do we Define the word
universe space and matter that's what it
is and here it is we put it in the
Universal movie so we know where exactly
it fits okay and it's a static concept
okay matter in space and there you see
it you know that's the universe it's not
a dynamic you don't have to see anything
moving in the universe you can take a
snapshot of whatever's in the universe
there you know in a single frame and
what you'll have is just space and
matter and that relation is what you the
Observer the guy who's looking at that
frame that's what's in the frame even if
you're not there you know that's all
that's in the frame okay all you have
there is space and matter that is the
definition of the word universe and the
word universe is
a static concept it's not a physical
object therefore you cannot say that the
Universe expands you cannot say that you
there's curvature in the universe you
cannot talk about what's outside the
universe because it's a concept okay you
can't none of those things that
mathematical physics does today can you
do in physics in math you can do
whatever you want because it's religion
you know all that stuff is just
calculations and measurements and uh and
you're followed by irrational
explanations in physics we have to have
a rational explanation for how this
universe works so that everybody
understands it and what a lot of these
people say is well we don't understand
the universe we cannot understand the
universe we do not understand father
Universe right why because
um he thinks differently than we do in
other words are the the the argument is
that our minds work a little different
than How the Universe works or how the
universe is supposed to be etc etc how
it is ETC
and all I can tell is one thing very
simple very simple if God Almighty
himself comes down to Earth today sits
next to you right and he explains to you
how gravity Works how magnetism works
you would understand how it works
you know he's not going to bring any
four-dimensionality or five
dimensionality or 26 dimensionality he's
going to say look this is how a magnet
attracts another we do not need five
Dimensions to explain how a magnet
attracts another you know like this
stuff we do not need
10 Dimensions explain this okay and
likewise we do not if we have uh you
know my famous experiment you let go of
a pencil right falls to the ground to
the table in this case and
um and so you got to answer what is the
mechanism hopefully we do not have to
rely on 26 Dimensions 10 11 4 5 or
whatever we should be God should be able
to explain it to you and say look this
is how that's done this is how I do this
magic trick that's how simple it is it's
baby stuff it's all these mathematicians
who went out there and say we got to do
it through measurement we got to do it
through equations
and they ended up with all ridiculous
and irrational explanations such as
bending of space-time and 26 dimensions
and so on
and so yeah that's where we are today
here we are thousands of years since we
started this process of trying to
explain especially gravity not a single
mathematician on planet Earth can
explain the mechanism of gravity
okay let's go with the questions and the
comments that people made okay
let's see if we can get to the bottom of
some of these one fellow says okay here
he goes he says uh look up physics
equation for Gravity okay below the
surface of the Earth it calculate zero
gravity at the center okay yeah because
everything points to the center okay
this applies to all Sears okay agreed
yeah gravity is maximum at the surface
so there cannot be a collapse
he says gravity is maxing up the surface
what is he saying he's saying something
is pulling towards the center that's
what he's saying but he said but he's
saying so there's no pull towards the
center but that's what gravity is a pull
towards the Sun so he doesn't understand
that he's got a contradiction there okay
black holes and uh and then he goes on
with other stuff okay so uh yeah he
fails right there that we can't we don't
have to go beyond that uh yeah if you're
pulled down to the Center of the Earth
then you are pulled to the Center of the
Earth and you can't say I'm not being
pulled to the Center of the Earth
because there's zero gravity there but
you're saying gravity is strongest at
the surface and what is gravity a pull
towards the center of the earth to the
center of the wall oh my God these poor
people I mean I wonder if they ever went
through kindergarten okay so here we
have another foul he says in invisible
Angels hold us all down okay I can
calculate the man does this mean Angels
hold us all down okay right uh
calculations cannot tell us if gravity
is medium By Angels or by robes or by
particles you're right okay does this
mean just hold this all down gravity is
about as real as Angels Ah that's a big
jump that he went there from one to the
other
um visible spectrum of light is Freeze
in free space doesn't exist for the Sun
or Stars
gross matter has to be involved to be
able to see the sun and stars and again
uh what what all these uh people want is
see and touch that's all they can do
and it's not like the the uh you know
what they should all be blind and
quadriplegic so they don't touch
anything they don't see anything okay
what they should do is think just sit
down close your eyes drink five beers if
necessary and try to visualize how this
universe works that's all they had to do
all these These Years try to imagine
what the mechanism is out there for
Gravity for magnetism for electricity
for the workings of the atom Etc you
know you have to try to visualize
and to visualize you're gonna need
objects you need to put something in
there to understand a mechanism okay you
can't put words such as field or energy
or charge because those are not physical
objects those are mathematical Concepts
which people think
are physical objects they treat them as
physical objects they treat space as a
physical object they treat the universe
the word universe as a physical object
none of those are obviously they're all
Concepts
okay uh fellow says uh your evidence
that gravity is a pulling force is a
quote from a physics Professor that you
have no respect for uh in other words uh
he's talking about uh Richard Mueller
from Berkeley and yeah I don't think uh
I have respect for any mathematician
because they all have these irrational
explanations of how this universe works
it says irrelevant that's my answer to
him Mueller was stating what newts uh
Newton right Newton's gravitation
equation describes you know you have
mass mastic about this distance squared
and that's all he's saying essentially
the pull force is Newton's equation okay
and it's a pull Force yeah pull yeah
it's not a push could have been said by
anyone uh evidence has nothing to do
with science he talks about evidence
what does evidence have to do with
science evidence is what the prosecutor
presents when he wants to convince the
jury he wants to sway
the jury in his favor to think like he
does and that's when he presents
evidence says hey here's the evidence
this is only that works on belief it
doesn't work on understanding okay uh it
could work on understanding but that's
not what they use it for they use it for
belief okay they want to make sure that
you're convinced of their theory of
their version religious folk introduce
evidence to persuade commands converted
and recruit the flock and science is
about explaining not about persuading
okay so don't use the word evidence ever
again especially not here okay
is it over there where all these other
people uh you know they like to use the
word evidence
okay
here we have uh I think it's Saint
fellas as uh my question is why do you
assume gravity is a pulling Force
my God
um well first of all it's the flat
earthers another ignoramuses who attempt
to explain gravity is a mechanism
involving push
and um
yeah well I don't assume gravity is a
pulling Force I make assumptions right
that's what I do I make an assumption
and what is the Assumption about it's
about invisible intangible mediators
that mother nature uses to do gravity
okay it's known as a hypothesis then we
begin the explanation of the mechanism
which is known as Theory okay that
gravity is a pulling mechanism where
these elongated mediators that's the
theory okay so you you when these people
talk about evidence they get into
trouble and then they say why do you
assume it's not an assumption the
assumption is the physical objects that
we are saying
we're assuming those exist out there we
make an assumption okay we make an
assumption so that you understand the
mechanism the theory of the physical
interpretation
and then we explain it so that you
understand not not that you believe not
so that you believe but that you
understand the mechanism then you can
reach your own conclusion in your own
dark basement okay and here uh here you
have it uh fellow says answers
essentially to this other fellow says
gravity is just another name to call
that pool yeah gravity is a pool Force
okay we have to explain pull and the
only force that the mathematicians have
never explained in the history of uh
science physics research is the force of
pull you will not find a force and pull
of pull in quantum mechanics you won't
find it in uh general relativity you
won't find it in string theory which are
the three branches of mathematical
physics never have they been able to
explain the force of pull in fact that's
what killed uh Newton because Newton
says look I got the equation mass mass
divided by distance Square so he had a
good notion that you had these two
things they have mass how much they
weigh how much matter they have and
they're separated by so much the closer
they are together the stronger the
gravity the farther they are apart the
weaker the gravity that's all he
understood but he says why when they're
close by why why is the number why is
the force between them stronger and he
he knew that was a pull Force but what
he could not explain it with is with
particles with discrete particles and
that's why he says I have no hypothesis
I feign no hypothesis because he could
not explain it with particles it never
occurred to him that all atoms on Earth
are connected to all atoms on the sun
and that's why the Earth doesn't fly out
of the solar system because they're
connected and uh you know and the reason
you know a spoon or a pencil falls to
the floor is because every atom of that
spoon or that pencil is connected to
every atom on earth now we can explain
why there is no action at a distance
it's that we cannot see or touch the
mediators and for that you just you have
to think and say what if what if what if
there are invisible
elongated mediators that connect every
atom to every atom in the universe now
we can explain things without using
action at a distance because we have a
mechanism we can all visualize do you
believe it we don't care that's your
problem that's religion we don't care
about belief we want you to understand
the mechanism okay and to criticize it
no problem that's that's your job
okay uh but um what I found out about
this who asked these questions is you
know this is what he looks like and uh
that's that's his picture he was he's a
cyclops so he couldn't see very well but
it turns out I think he photoshopped his
picture because I think he's missing in
here as well because he doesn't hear
very well either okay he says you can't
push with a ball
I never said that I said pull with a
ball but you can push with a rope yes
you can push with a rope how do you
figure okay and yeah so uh uh you you
can pull you can't pull with a ball try
pulling with the ball you know here I'll
do the experiment for you if uh if it's
too exp you know here it is uh two balls
are touching we can understand push I
can push with that but you know if I
pull this one out it doesn't pull this
one
so try it at home you know don't take my
word for it but you can't pull with a
ball you can't pull with discrete
particles and that's what all these
mathematicians have been talking about
for the last 400 years at least they're
trying to do everything with particles
discrete particles and that's why they
don't have the force a pull okay and
that's what gravity is and that's why
they have never never figured out
gravity because they they need to
explain pull and they don't have a
mechanism to explain pull right okay
um
so what do these people propose they
propose uh what is known as La Sage or
Casimir effect type uh mechanisms and
here I've Illustrated that okay and it
started really with lucretius he's the
first one that came up with this notion
fascio in the days of Newton came up
with the same idea let's say it's about
100 a few not about 50 years later
Kramer rediker Casimir you know all
these people came up with this nonsense
shadowy kind of thing I think uh also uh
uh what's his name
um Renee Descartes uh suggested
something like this as well it's a
shadow mechanism it's saying like if you
remove particles between two things then
the particles on the outside pushes them
together that's a sense the the particle
way of producing pull and it's uh yeah
it's what they call a um
there's a ptolemaic explanation it says
irrational as you can you know they they
have to go out of their way to explain
pull through push because they cannot
explain pull unless you put an elongated
mediator then you can explain pull and
then you can explain gravity but if
you're going to try to do a push with
particles and Etc well you know good
luck with that just show me the
mechanism point the mechanism and we're
talking about mechanism that means
you got to go in there and make a movie
or or show me a movie that someone made
or whatever but show me the mechanism of
how the Earth uh or how a pencil Falls
to Earth using your particles
okay your discrete particles and we'll
see if you have any success because
nobody has in the last 400 years they
sure would give you a Nobel Prize if you
can explain gravity with particles
quantum
as long ago abandoned you know
explaining gravity
okay
um
so here we have uh he said can you push
with a with a rope yes you can first you
can pull hopefully you can do that you
know just tie it around the dungeon pull
on and you'll see that the donkey comes
closer to you but then it turns out that
you can torque a rope and you can push
with a rope as well okay actually it's a
thump that the thing at the opposite end
receives okay
like a little torsion okay that's what
it is and uh so this all says says the
following
he says talking a rope that is connected
to two objects will bring them closer
together and push them and not push them
away have you ever bothered to actually
do an experiment
okay uh well today we're gonna do an
experiment for him okay let's find out
if he ever did an experiment okay so the
first question in the first answer is
only if the links shorten
okay only then can you say that yeah it
draws the two objects together
so here you have my row let me remove
this for a second here okay so that I
can show you something here okay here's
my rope okay my famous rope
okay and if you target
if you torque it okay the links become
shorter and the two ends come closer to
each other my two hands you know come
closer to each other okay now what
happens if you untort it well then
they're farther apart
okay we got that so far I mean this is
not difficult right in here let me we
took a picture with my son okay here it
is okay
um if if you torque it you see the links
up on the top are shorter and it
measured the whole thing measured 49
centimeters and then we untalked it and
you can see that they're farther apart
53 centimeters four centimeters four
more centimeters okay so hopefully
everybody understands that but that's
only true if
um if the links become shorter
okay because of the links become longer
okay then you're not pulling okay uh you
are farther apart and when all these
people uh who don't uh have not uh
understood the Rope model yet have not
taken the trouble to investigate it they
think the torque is you know like this
on both sides and they say if you target
the two things come together but that's
not what we're proposing okay we're
saying first that uh the um atoms slide
through the ropes okay here it is okay
so it's like a beat on an abacus it's
sliding through the roof because the
ropes make up the atom itself the
especially one uh thread goes around and
forms the electron shell or membrane and
the other one goes through the center
and forms the uh proton star okay so
you're not pulling really that's one
issue you're sliding through the ropes
that's what the atoms are doing okay and
you're sliding through every rope into
your Universe okay every time you move
now that's one issue the other one is
that if you torque a rope okay and you
can do this at home the guy talked about
experiment you know you took a rope and
what you'll find is that you know and
you type far very far away right you
torque it you'll find that the links
where you torque it are shorter and they
become longer as you walk towards you
know the other end they become longer
and longer because the torsion has not
yet reached the center
so what you'll see is that they go from
short to Long
okay and what did we say that if the
links are longer they tend to push right
there's this motion away from you okay
and just think of it that way it's not
exactly what happens what I'm just
saying is think of it that way it's not
that you know when you torque uh the
whole rope immediately torques in
opposite directions and the two opposes
come closer together which is what this
guy had in mind so you gotta you gotta
look at exactly what's happening with a
rope model when when the sun when the
sun is torquing the ropes at very high
frequency you know you're talking about
uh uh frequency that we would not
receive here we would we don't receive
the frequency that the sun torques the
Rope at source by the time it gets to us
you know the links are uh unmate they
get longer and longer and longer and we
don't receive it in the uh gamma ray or
or you know even higher x-ray gamma ray
and some other ultra high frequency we
get that same thing by the time it
reaches us is a longer wavelength okay
so we might receive it as x-ray
something comes out as gamma that we
receive as x-ray or whatever so you got
to keep these things in mind
um when you torque a rope you can push
and what you're doing really is not
pushing but you're torquing the end of
or whatever's at the end okay and then
you got to think of the end as this this
is what the surface of an atom looks
like like a ball of yarn okay and so and
each one of those strands is the same
thing that the Rope is so the Rope turns
into the electron shell and the proton
dandelion the star that's on the inside
so you got to look at the model before
you talk you haven't understood the
model there's many things you got to
understand about how light is explained
under the Rope model and how gravity is
explained under the role model A lot of
these people they just jump and they say
the first thing that comes to mind
without understanding what we're
proposing so they're putting words in
our mouth
okay and here we have uh another version
of that okay so it says turkey and rope
is connected to two objects we'll bring
it into oh okay
the same power no I just wanted to show
the same the second thing here unless
the ropes slide through the uh balls in
other words if the atoms are sliding
like beads on an abacus then you don't
have to worry about you know
bringing them together because they
could slide inwards or they could slide
out irrespective of what happens to the
Rope the reason uh Einstein was able to
um
say that
the speed of light which is a constant
is independent of the motion of the
source is because the source slides
through the ropes it doesn't push on the
roofs doesn't pull on the ropes it
slides through them because the Rope
becomes
the surface and the star in the center
of the F okay so you got to look at the
model so that you understand it okay and
uh here we have uh
give me a second here had a question
here but
okay if I says we know black holes Exist
by detecting the gravitational ripples
when they Collide okay so again he's
saying that a black hole exists simply
because we detect some kind of Ripple
with some equipment that we have here on
Earth and we say far away uh billions of
uh light years away uh there was a
collision between black holes
we have no idea what a black hole is
it's in fact we do it's zero Dimension
it's nothing but they think it's a lot
of mass okay
so they have these two masses which are
mathematical Concepts they have these
two masses these two mathematical
Concepts abstract mathematical Concepts
just weights that uh uh Collide they
allegedly produce ripples in space time
which is another mathematical concept
and we detect those we detect those
gravitational waves of space-time of
this concept
and they say we detected it with our
equipment
so I don't know what they're measuring
be and they don't know what they're
measuring because they cannot uh draw
they cannot tell us what it is that's
waving and for sure they cannot tell us
what is colliding because the two things
that are collided are Zero Dimensional
has no matter because crushed all matter
out of existence has no uh size no
volume zero volume means no matter and
if there's no matter there's no Mass so
they have we have absolutely nothing two
nothing's collided and they produce
ripples in an abstract concept
mathematical concept called SpaceTime
and they detected it with some kind of
tuning form
yeah sure okay and so yeah this is the
problem with doing experiments and not
understanding How the Universe Works not
visualizing not being able to explain
how the universe works just focusing on
math and saying well we detected
something and this is our conclusion
that two black holes collided
yeah please draw the black hole before
you Collide it okay we want to see a how
you draw a Zero Dimensional Singularity
okay so yeah again it's useless to uh to
have a discussion with people who are
using abstract Concepts as physical
objects and if you don't understand that
you don't understand anything about
physics all you do is all you're doing
is math okay okay follow says in Bill's
lexicon a black hole isn't a thing
correct it's not a thing in my lexicon
oh oh he's got new lexicon let's find
out a black hole is a thing even if a
misconception okay thing what is a thing
an existing material
yeah see the problem is uh same problem
that we had
um with David Hume and um Emmanuel Kant
they thought that the word exists is a
synonym of the word object of the word
thing they say thing in in
um and uh exist are synonyms because
they could not tell
you know what the word exists adds to
the word object the word thing to the
word something okay and yes it does add
something that's what they never figured
out it adds location uh exist means
object with location without an uh
without location all we have is an
object it could be anything that's got
shape uh it could be a cube an ideal
cube of geometry could be a circle any
of those is is fine because they have
shape what they don't have is location
only when they have location does it
become can you talk about existence of
that object okay so no thing is not the
same thing as an object a thing is not
the same thing as existence and if you
have that wrong you got everything all
your reasoning is garbage and you can't
say anything so you got to defend your
definition that's where your whole
reasoning stops you got to defend that
definition you can't say thing is
existence
okay you can't use the word exist the
Define thing because you need the
defined thing before you define the word
exists
and you haven't understood that either
you learned that in who knows where and
material you can't use the word material
to define the word thing because
material matter right is a bunch of
things that's what matter is so you
can't say things matter no because
matter is many things so again you don't
know the basics of how to define words
so your definition is garbage poppy
irrational and obviously if you get an
irrational definition all your
conclusions
are irrational because they're based on
uh language that you cannot defend you
have to defend your definition not say
this is my lexicon we don't care about
your Lexicon we want a lexicon that we
all understand we all have to be on the
same page and what you're telling us is
that you have your own definitions that
you understand yourself and you just
want everybody to listen to you and not
to criticize you okay no you have to
defend your definitions and we defend
our definitions you an object that which
has shape existence
object plus location okay we're done and
if you have a problem with that well
yeah you gotta say what is wrong with
that and again we're talking about
physics and science how you know a word
that we can use consistently right
rationally
and that definition can be used
rationally consistently meaning
scientifically your definition is
poppycock it's nonsense it's it's been
done been there done that you know
uh in Rand was one of those who used
that irrational definition that's why
she could never figure out this how this
universe works see just defined it for
the purposes of politics but not for
physics okay but whenever someone
defines the word object rationally
whether they know in existence as well
whether they know it or not they stepped
the line over into physics they be they
want to become physicists or they are in
the realm of physics they're in the
discipline of physics whether they know
it or not so the fact that in Rand you
know defined words for philosophy
politics whatever you want to call it
religion we don't care uh as soon as she
tries to define the word object in the
word exists she stepped the line over
into physics and we're going to
criticize her as a physicist not as a
philosopher or a religious fanatic or
whatever she was
okay and here we have uh I think the
same fella and he says Bill argues we
must kill the Observer I know I think
this is someone else or remove the
senses correctly you got to remove the
senses uh no senses because it's all
subjective in order for uh in order to
offer a viable rational idea no it's
it's an objective one
versus a subjective one but why must
this be so because you're otherwise
you're subjective you're saying you're
drugged and you drank 10 liters of uh of
beer and you're saying that
um you saw something you saw you know
extraterrestrials come down to your
backyard yeah sure okay uh that's why we
don't we don't care about observers What
You observe explain the mechanism
explain why your grass is burnt okay oh
it was all this radiation then the
Extraterrestrial hand yeah that's your
interpretation maybe maybe you burn the
grass with a match who knows observers
are an integral part of such an exchange
observers are the ones developing such
ideas after all and in turn sharing them
with other observers yeah all these drug
addicts they they share all their other
Visions right there would be no such
ideas without observers and thinkers
yeah
the issue here is objectivity okay
observers introduce subjectivity no
matter how you put it okay we don't need
subjectivity not in physics because
we're trying to find out what exists and
what exists is objective you have to
define the word exist whatever meets the
definition that exists by definition
pursuant to the definition and you
cannot say
in science we don't say at least God
exists or God doesn't exist or I don't
know if God exists or not that's not
science that's religion all of that is
religion in science we say let us assume
God exists
and then you explain your theory or
whatever your theory is how God created
the universe whatever you want to
explain and we understand your theory
we understand your theory we do not
believe it maybe some people might
believe it some people won't but the
important thing is we understand what
you're trying to tell us we understand
what's going through your head we
understand the mechanism you are
proposing for how this universe came to
be okay you're trying to explain
something and for that you make an
assumption it's called an assumption a
hypothesis and God can only be an
assumption a hypothesis God cannot be a
theory and that's the first thing you
need to learn okay so yeah you need to
define words and these people never
learn how to define words they think
they can Define it anyway they want or
any way that suits their argument
that's not my case here I'm not defining
to suit my argument I'm defining so that
you understand the definition first so
that you can criticize it find out
what's wrong with it and then because
I'm going to use that definition for a
theory to explain a theory so that you
can follow my presentation my
dissertation okay that's the way it
works okay and if there's something
wrong with the definition hey bring it
on we'd love to hear it and show us what
you're gonna we can't leave the room
okay we're gonna lock all the doors
we're all in this conference room eight
billion people here right and the only
way you can leave is when you have a
definition of the word object and the
word exists you don't have a definition
you cannot open the door and leave
because we cannot do physics without the
definition of the word object and the
word exists
by that I'll see you next Sunday bye-bye